yo what up what up it's your boy wiz
khalifa man and make sure you check me
out on the bootleg calf podcast
bootleg cab show we got a special guest
in here return guest my guy
he's got a new album coming out friday
friday bruv multiverse multiverse bro
yes yeah man so i heard the album uh
about two months ago and i was [ __ ]
gone off with some mushrooms okay
and you played the album like eight or
eight times in a row in the studio and i
was just sunk into the couch and it
sounded like the greatest [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my life i don't know why
everybody keeps doing like hell and
mushrooms around me and getting [ __ ]
up
yeah so it's funny though yeah look what
i heard was amazing
i changed it a lot from it i've heard
i've heard that i've heard there's some
new stuff because i feel like memory
lane i didn't i don't know if i heard
memory lane no that song wasn't recorded
at that time
there was uh there's still some songs
from that time that are in there on the
album but no i kind of i reworked it i'm
still reworking it like the [ __ ] comes
out on friday i'm still reworking it
like right now what's like the absolute
latest you could turn it in though um
what is there's ways of going about it
there's the music side there's the
artwork side there's a track listening
side so there's just things that you can
still you know get and work in your
favor
there's samples that just got cleared
last week you know what i mean so
thursday 7 p.m comes and you decide
track 2 feels like a track 12. i could
do that you could do that yeah yeah okay
it's it's possible you know that that
happens anything's possible yeah yeah uh
why multiverse
um
[ __ ]
it started out kind of just being like a
name that i landed on
and then it started to just you know
take its own life and just be this world
that i kind of exist in on my own and
then when i listen to the music i'm like
it really is my own multiverse it's me
showing different sides of myself
and it's also uh me not chasing any
trends or trying to sound like anything
that's being done
so it's it's something that on its own
you know what i mean it stands out on
its own in its own yeah when i heard
like at least the version i heard i felt
it was like a nice representation of
like everything you can do yes for sure
because you got trap wiz you got
there are so many things you can you you
you are like capable of doing like a
[ __ ] well i am a martial artist but
it's like martial arts i got so many
different styles and to bring them all
together and just use them where they're
appropriate um that was the goal and to
also just show off and flex a couple
different skills that people you know
might or might not associate with you
know my legacy so uh yeah i want to
thank you because your workout videos
motivated me oh yeah because i would in
a good way okay i'm down like listen
i'm down 25 pounds right now
and i was like man if this guy can be in
the studio all night and then go to the
gym every [ __ ] day uh this is when
you were like going crazy on reels like
10 times a day yeah yeah see ya um thank
you man but uh dude i've been working
and i've also taken note i've been
working out on my draws in my garage
every [ __ ] day way better right yeah
you don't have these heavy shorts
bouncing around it's just freedom you
know what i'm saying yeah free from all
trends uh
more workout videos coming for the
summer you know i had to take a little
break just so people would miss them and
there was some crazy interviews like i
would hear like women talking about me
in like a wild-ass way i was like whoa
uh well you are out here you know listen
you know what i'm saying i mean you know
that wasn't the goal i was i understand
that wasn't that literally trying to
show my workout right i happen to be
comfortable with myself
so showing the workout while showing the
prince a little extra extra yeah
for those who had to care about that but
you know uh more workouts coming for the
summer because yeah we're trying we're
getting shredded on tour
i got some new [ __ ] that i want people
to tap into
and i'm hella happy that you know that
[ __ ] with you and you did yeah for
real homies like you know what i mean
cause there'd be times where i'd be like
i'd see you the night before yeah and
i'd be like damn we were
just raging and the next morning you're
like yeah no i love that [ __ ] dog like
i'm i'm still gonna be doing it on the
road every night
we're gonna freaking rage and then i'm
gonna be up in the morning
in my draws working out what is your
regiment like is it how many times a
week do you have to work out five days a
week so five days a week and then how do
you break the days down is it like arms
shoulders well we can get technical so
monday is leg day tuesdays chest
and a little bit of shoulders uh
wednesday is back then we go right back
to legs and then we do chest and then we
do back again um yeah yeah and the
biceps and triceps just fall in there
because yeah well we do like multiple
blocks so it's like you know we might do
a little bit of uh pushing like real
heavy [ __ ] and then we might do some
just some functional [ __ ] and then throw
a little bit of biceps in there for some
pump and some some try some kickbacks
some you know some [ __ ] uh skull
crushers like there's all different
types of [ __ ] to do that aren't like
your normal
heavy lifting but they still get the job
done so we just mix all of that stuff in
there do you ever see old videos and old
pictures of yourself when you were like
skinny ass whiz with you got one of the
craziest metabolisms of all time clearly
uh but like and you just said like god
damn bro
because you were skinniest it's [ __ ]
sickening bro like i'd be like that's
gross i'll be like get that footage out
of there this is the you know what i
mean because
there's lifestyle change that goes with
that so when you see that person not
that person but when you see yourself uh
not at your best or on your way to your
best
you don't really look at that
in the best way like for me i
love the transformation but it's how i
feel and it's mentally a transformation
as well like i can't live without the
gym so back then i wasn't thinking about
you know waking up and working out or
eating correctly or you know weighing
myself and making sure that i'm at the
appropriate weight for you know what i
mean like i wasn't doing none of that
[ __ ] so the mind frame
it wasn't you know eat like food wise
you're just eating a bunch of proteins i
ate everything i want to um i could have
burgers if i mean you got that
metabolism i love raising canes i just
got to make sure i get a bunch of uh
calories in that's the main thing it's
like getting the the right amount of
calories and i eat a lot of fruits and
vegetables because i want to get in the
right type of way i don't want to just
be like you know big and [ __ ]
constipated
like so yeah so there's a science to it
and raising canes is the best though i
[ __ ] with keynes bro but where is there
a canes i mean they just opened one in
burbank they made one in burbank so
that's that's the go-to yeah
see you you have to send somebody over
there right because it's a [ __ ] mess
dude shout out to adam a shout out
but see there's no way you're going and
waiting in that line in burbank
i'll do it if i have do you do uh cause
what i do i get the kaniak double toast
and like four
i
sauces
[ __ ] with the coleslaw no i never ate
coleslaw like i get offended if somebody
i don't even know why they included in
their meals anymore
there's multiple reasons that i could
name
but we'll just leave it at that ice he's
got an endorsement deal with raising
canes yeah i think i think i invested in
raising canes as well
no no no no
not yet
is that on the way yeah not yet what
snoop hooked me up with that place snoop
is the man yo he called me with todd and
was like
[ __ ]
if y'all gonna do a deal with anybody i
gotta do it
with wiz i'm like bro why are you
calling me just like trying to give me
millions of dollars like i love you bro
good guy amazing so that's all so you're
going to be an investor and endorser of
raising gains officially we're going to
see we're going to pull it out you're
going to be working in the drive-through
like iced tea was
he did that yeah
i'll do it for a day yeah why not it's
whatever
you got to get the cane sauce at the
crib i got to do like a like a
a multiverse meal with raisin canes
that's the wave
everyone's doing meals yeah yeah raisin
canes is the wave man yeah yep blazing
blazing canes
like a like a oh i'll do my own sauce
pause that's what it'll be you get your
own sauce pause you're gonna change
pause yeah yeah you're gonna change up
the raisin the cane sauce the best part
of the restaurant
just for exclusive we're coming up with
ideas right now i like that yeah yeah
the other thing about canes is like it's
very like this is what we have yeah we
have chicken we have fries yeah yeah we
have toast lemonade
that's what we got yeah yep ain't
playing no guys i don't think you can
get ranch there
hell no you can't even ask for it but
the texas toast is crazy texas toasted
smacking is insane 100
um how like when it comes to the martial
arts [ __ ] man like
obviously shout out to pfl pro fight
league which is what you're uh a part of
yep uh i just got done watching one of
the fights a few weeks ago on espn it
was crazy um
but i know that like you're extremely
passionate about martial arts but like
how often are you like actively sparring
it depends on like when i'm on camera
and [ __ ]
so if i got to be like on camera or if i
got a show i obviously don't want to
have like a black eye right because it
happens it's cut or something like that
yeah it happens
and i got a lot of face jewelry and [ __ ]
too so it's like i don't be feeling like
taking all this [ __ ] out
so i'll probably spar like maybe like
three times a month that's not bad we
can get it in and then on the road you
got breeze holding the the bags
we hold pads every day okay i'm learning
new techniques and we hitting you know
hitting hard
but as far as like sparring that's for
me that's like good to just move around
and stay active because it's different
from hitting the pads and actually being
like in a fighting scenario right like
having three three to five rounds or
somebody really throwing punches and
kicks at you so sometimes you run out of
like you run out of moves like you'll
know like eight to ten things to do just
from hitting the pads but then when you
get in there and start mixing it up you
only got like two or three moves so you
gotta you gotta fight more so you know
what to do in those situations your
footwork gets a little bit better
stamina gets a little bit better like
you start to know when to you know
push a little bit more when hold back
defense gets a lot better
so you know i like working on all of
that stuff have you and ot done a spar
session yet no we have because you guys
train at the same place you guys are
good friends we're a different weight
class i understand that and you got some
long legs if you guys doing muay thai
and you don't really kick all like that
and
we're those types of friends where it's
like that one we would just rather like
spar somebody else like there's certain
people where you like yo like you could
mess around you could play you know what
i mean
but we haven't gotten there yet yeah i
haven't i haven't asked him he
they shout out today they're dope day is
on there they're though and they were
they before the days were they they yeah
they were they they have been they for a
while they've been there for a while
that sounds funny they've been they
[Laughter]
you can't get mad if somebody says that
like no not for removing that from them
be like if somebody doesn't be like man
y'all are they
ah you get it see what you you did that
though stop being they man
it's they ass fools i like it and we
won't get cancelled you said it i said
it yeah yeah i'm applying it just to my
friend group who just like you know if
this guy does some they ass [ __ ] i'll be
like
yes
yes
yes we did that
so days on the project
yeah day is on there not demi lovato the
group day see i'm not i don't know any
days no i do know they i do know that um
but yeah they they the band is on um
they've been fired for a very long time
yeah i've been [ __ ] with their music
for a long ass time like since it was
like underground low-key you know what i
mean for sure but um we work with hit
maker all together we all be writing
records and [ __ ] like that so sometimes
a verse can end up here a hook end up
there uh a idea you know what i'm saying
like things get mixed and mesh but we
were really all like locked in on this
album and trying to create a sound and i
think about five records came out
that we all worked on together um
on this album you got a great like uh i
feel like you got great chemistry with
him yeah that's my partner bro like i
used i came up with him like when i was
signing warner brothers i used to record
with him and rob holiday and like they
used to let me sleep at they cried the
young bird days yeah when he was young
bird yeah and i was buying weed from say
yeah days yeah oh yeah good times a
young [ __ ] man uh like early twitter
days you know what i mean i would hit
them up anytime i came to l.a like that
was my that was my partner and he was
wild back then like in the club doing
hell of [ __ ] i don't know if he explains
it i'll let him explain what he used to
do but i wasn't into all that crap he
told me uh
like last month on the show he's like he
had eight chicks at one time and like
like peak slum slum life he was like
yeah i had eight chicks at once i was
like like in the bed or like in the bed
oh that sounds about right yeah yeah i
mean i'm cool with that yeah yeah but
just
there's a lot of other stuff going on
that i wasn't you know what you're over
under there is it eight or is it more
women under yeah once
for me yeah personally i don't give all
all that information doesn't that feel
like a little excessive like all those
women if i had eight chicks at once i'd
be stressed out i feel like it wouldn't
be as fun as it sounds well there's
certain girls in certain countries who
feel like you know men deserve that
you know so
it's it's normal for some people and
then for some people it's just like what
the hell i just mean in terms of like
the practicality of like what are we
doing like you know just so much going
on there's some creative individuals out
there bro
[Laughter]
so days on the project and and and then
you and then uh me mostly but i want to
like shout out my producers and my band
kenny he did a real great job of
bringing the music together um we sat
down and made a lot of original stuff
that when people hear it it's like the
real dna the album that's going to give
it the texture that's going to make it
like really difficult to copy and then
it's going to change how people you know
put together their albums and really
want to you know
just view their music so i was really
happy to be able to get with kenny cj
mike and then other members of my band
to just like create something from
scratch dog that nobody's really doing
um tm is on the album as well
uh girl talk is on the album which is a
real big deal for me because
him being from pittsburgh that just
provided a sound that like is so
nostalgic
but you know next level because he's
always been ahead of the curve like just
being a producer and a dj and just
having a grip on like you know
sonically what what people you know is
gonna [ __ ] them up so it was good to be
able to tap in with the homes and you
guys just did the the crit currency we
did smoked is and that album is amazing
it's a great album it's amazing
sonically it sounds so good it's such a
like it just reminded me of like when i
like the just the blog era yeah it's
really really good it's really good [ __ ]
and they play that [ __ ] in like nobu and
catch and stuff like that so it's good
to see what type of crowds gravitate
towards those sounds
and um you know when you're when you're
making a project
for me i intentionally try to grab
certain ears or you know bring people
along with me it's like hey you might be
in the trap but let's go to nobu brother
you know what i'm saying enjoy yourself
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners our
family at odd socks go to
oddssocksofficial.com
right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys
so you can see how fly the draws are
ladies and gentlemen because they are
fly by the way they just gave me my own
pair of odd socks go on my social media
and you could see them uh i don't know
if they're going to be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on them besides my wife and
she don't even want to wear him there we
go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks on socksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off let's
get back to the interview um i put
together uh um
best mixtapes of all time list last year
and i had cushion oranges number one
thank you
i think it's the greatest mixtape ever i
appreciate that uh
i think i think it was like that i think
i had like rick ross's rich forever up
there
i would say um if you're meek mill dream
chaser
juice it would be so far gone so far
gone so far gone to me is number one
because it came out before because the
thing about so far gone is like not too
far after so far gone
a lot of it ended up on like a like a
version you go by best buy i feel like
cushion origins was like a true mixtape
because we barely just got it on dsps
like i don't know [ __ ] last year it
felt like okay
but well i'll let you handle that but
it's like like obviously you know
recently you celebrated the anniversary
of that project like um
do you like when you look at your
discography like where do you rank that
amongst like the rolling papers or the
rolling papers too or like because you
know i feel like you have classics you
know what i mean yeah hell yeah all my
[ __ ] is crazy um
i would put cushion orange juice at
number one for sure uh that was my
ill-matic like that was my you know if
you want to listen to wiz like number
one the first project for a lot of
people
is cushion orange juice you know what
i'm saying like i had 10 mixtapes like
star power before
you know what i'm saying like i love
flight school flight school was hard
high school
you know which one had to tap my whole
body on my whole body i think that's my
high school yeah and uh bird after
rolling was crazy you know taylor alder
dice was nuts cabin fever is crazy
yo both cabins don't play with me stay
with me but
you know if you want to like be like yo
all right i'm going to start with one
whiz project because that's what a lot
of people are going to start doing at a
certain point or even probably now
because i'm 10 years in the game and
like where the [ __ ] do i start cushion
orange juice for sure is there an effort
to try to get the taylor all the all the
dices and the cabin fevers and all that
on dsps because now that we got cushion
orange juice because i feel like i mean
they're doing this slowly um
uh that's more like for the fans and i
love how the fans want to be on on it on
dsps but music was made so different
back then i still have the datpiff app
on my phone just to listen to people
hate that [ __ ] i was just having a
conversation with somebody well they
don't hate it i'm sorry oh my bad
that piff kp i love y'all shout out to
somebody was talking about the
functioning of it right the fact that
they can't play it and do certain things
right right right right whatever
whatever you know that's nerd [ __ ] and
that's the type of [ __ ] that i talk to
people and listen to them but i give
feedback on what they like and what they
don't like so regardless of if i want it
on dsps or not the fans the people
everybody they really really want that
[ __ ] and they love that [ __ ] but what i
was saying is music was made differently
back then um we were just grabbing songs
or samples
hell yeah throw that [ __ ] out there
there's a z share file download go on
tour [ __ ] make a billion dollars and
you know they started to get pissed they
were like [ __ ] like these dudes are
making money off of like you know
whatever whatever so
they changed up how you can uh
uh digest that [ __ ] and really put it
out there so that's why i took a little
bit of amount of time for for my records
to clear yo your freshman cover is one
of the most legendary freshman covers
ever thank you can you give us like a a
story about that day that shoot like
what was like one of your fondest
memories of shooting um my fondest
memory was probably we all went to the
studio the night before
uh me currency
uh shipes had brought uh nip through
french was there big sean was there
um
yeah we all just went to the studio that
night and that was the first time i ever
have uh halal food you ever had
yeah of course and the first time i had
it was in new york too yeah yeah so like
she's like y'all gotta [ __ ] have
halal so we all came to the studio and
we smoked hey hello we figured out that
[ __ ] is like 10 bucks later like it's
not [ __ ] exotic at all it's like at a
cart outside yeah
but it was bomb it was like a cool new
york [ __ ] yeah and like we wrote three
or four songs like all together me
currency knit
uh big sean
and french like we all sat in the studio
and just wrote some songs together were
these records [ __ ] some ended up on
currencies mixtape at the time some
ended up on nips mixtape at the time
some ended up on french mixtape at the
time some ended up on my mixtape at the
time so they all like scattered they
were scattered around yeah yeah but you
could like go back and check the footage
out there's footage from day to day on
there
and uh yeah it was cool i think like the
whole photo shoot was more of a blur
because it was so many [ __ ] in there
and they was trying to interview us and
it was trying to
you know uh
uh
it was just it was a lot of you know
when you got young energy like i knew
what i was doing but a lot of other
people were like
you know what i'm saying so
it was pretty standoffish like at the
shoot but uh hey how close were you
because i remember when you jumped on
the super high remix yeah
it i think was human currency was on the
right hooks and i remember
i don't i can't even listen to the
normal version of that record because
that remix is so classic but i remember
there was like rumblings of you possibly
joining mmg at the time like was there
ever like oh did that ever get close to
the finish line rick ross is my man bro
and he's another one shout out to
mcqueen shout out
to there bamboo shout out to brett
um he's another one who's like snoop
who's like never stopped throwing me
alley oops or just putting you know me
in the game and just doing things to
help me out and he'll reach out
personally or tell people like yo [ __ ]
with wiz and he's so cool man like i
love that dude so the story of how that
went down is um i was i think i did the
mixtape monday on uh on mtv you remember
that [ __ ] remember that [ __ ] yeah
yeah like that was a big deal so i did
cushion orange juice and i was like i
gotta be on [ __ ] mixtape monday
and they were like you could do it but
we're not sending nobody to film you i
was like [ __ ] y'all i got my own film
crew right so i feel my own [ __ ] like i
film my own intro i feel my uh my
interviews i film like my little video
parts in the studio and [ __ ] like that
and they they aired it and he's seen
that [ __ ] he was like this [ __ ] it's
hard so he called me personally uh he he
hit me up through spiff spiff was uh
tv yeah
and sam sneak on dj yeah yeah dj sam
sneak they he hit excuse me he hit me up
through them called me personally was
like yo i [ __ ] with you heavy fly down
to atlanta come to my crib let's just
chill record some songs or whatever i'm
like hell yeah [ __ ] you're rick ross
right this is like peak mmg [ __ ] crazy
after big meech and all that yeah i'm
like oh hell yeah
so i went down there
he had a pile of wheaties like yo roll
up he took me sneaker shopping he took
me to go get some food he took me to go
get some tattoos we recorded the verses
uh separately like i did my verse in
pittsburgh and spitter did his verse uh
in new orleans because that's where he
was like yo i gotta tap in with both of
y'all like y'all smoking y'all doing
this so we did our verses and then we
flew down there and we shot the video
like that day
spit a left but i stayed another day and
just chilled and then by the time i got
home he called me again and was like yo
i want to sign you there's that other
thing
and i'm like
bruv i just started my own label right
taylor gang just started just started i
was like a lot of people don't know like
i got out of a deal at warner but these
[ __ ] are trying to double back and
sign me again and i'm about to get a
hell of a lot more money so after you
left warner the first time yeah they try
to bring you back well the same people
were at atlantic at the time why no like
yeah i mean it was the same
[ __ ] okay okay so the same team
who was at warner ended up over at
atlantic and that's how you ended up at
atlanta that's not how i ended up there
but they ended up having to deal with me
again because i had an anr who was crazy
about me and he brought me to atlantic
and they were like
bro we just had that kid he was over
there and he was like nah but he's like
he's that dude blah blah blah he's gonna
do this and they're like so
you mean to tell us we gotta sign the
same [ __ ] twice and give him
more money the second time so yeah i
took the money and i had to tell rick
ross like
we're keeping it on the low because like
i didn't want to tell people i was
signing another deal like you know what
i mean like it just wasn't my thing i
didn't want people to take away from the
fact that i was doing all of that [ __ ]
myself yeah making my own youtubes going
on tour doing all my own merch i didn't
want nobody stepping in and taking no
credit or any of that so
they didn't come into the picture
by people until like black and yellow
and [ __ ] but we had already been you
know what i mean talking so that's what
i had to tell rose was like you know i'm
talking to atlantic i'm finna make this
happen but we could always be family we
could always be cool that's big man yeah
man it was good and that's always been a
big homie man he showed me so much love
yo and he still does talk about taylor
gang obviously i think back to when you
guys had the uh double xl cover right um
and i just think that like in terms of
you just being like a ceo
i don't feel like sometimes you get the
credit you deserve man because i feel
like we always look at whiz as like this
fun guy but your [ __ ] your business
acumen is so crazy and your leadership
is just like a guy running a label if we
think about ty juicy j and we can go on
and on shout out to chevy shout out to
fed the god
um
what is the like what is the label
looking like now you know what i'm
saying like obviously fed's going on the
uh road with you um who who's officially
taylor gang in 2022
obviously there's people who are going
to be taylor gang forever yeah yeah um
but in terms of just like who's on the
label the thing the thing that we did
which was real smart is we uh started a
management company as well
so we manage a lot of artists that
aren't necessarily signed exactly
you know what i mean so that's why
maybe i might not get looked at as you
know blah blah blah but when it comes to
like making and
actually growing careers that's kind of
more what we're into is like
starting with people before their their
superstars and [ __ ] like that it's easy
to grab somebody and kind of just do
whatever you know what i mean and if
that's the path and that's a lot of
people's path
and it works and it looks good and it
sounds good but i much rather like build
like you said take them on the road
[ __ ] media train them like get give
them those develop an artist people
don't develop artists anymore they
really don't they just find a hit and
put them out there before they're really
ready for
the world
and uh what we do is we give people
opportunities to uh you know grow their
own business so you can get your own
publishing you can do all of these
things on your own
you have a choice whether you want to
you know what i'm saying be with us
so yeah
that's just that's just how that is and
i see it
better for business that way because
that way like things don't really go
the way that they're supposed to we're
not signing for a [ __ ] five years
right you can go yourself away and
there's no hard feelings and you can
take everything that you learn you know
what i'm saying apply it to the rest of
your career apply that be great that's
that's beautiful how uh obviously you
and logic hitting the road all summer
you know you are a guy who
consistently runs the summer when it
comes to these tours yeah it's been
[ __ ] what three years now
it's since the last one yeah 2019 was
the last time i went on tour but before
that i feel like it was like every
summer yeah it was it was like a thing
obviously the pandemic [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's that's always been
our thing man hitting these
amphitheaters
um
we're real solid with live nation and
you know we just put on a great show we
bring a lot of people
the lineup is always good and it's just
it's just a vibe i remember
i remember the first time i saw you was
that either
uh rock the bells are pre paid dues one
of them one of them oh yeah that was way
back in the day way back and you were
just walking through the crowd too
um but the first time i saw you like i
feel like your first like huge tour was
probably the rolling papers tour with
you and big sean
in terms of like you doing like those
big venues i remember seeing you at the
joint in vegas yeah yeah what are like
things that like because i feel like
your live show now is so
it's just so like
flawless like you know but like like
when it comes to
doing a new tour there new things you
try to add into the yeah yeah i'm always
uh trying to be as creative and and you
know shocking as possible but i stay in
my lane too
and i'm also like very money conscious
like i'm not one of those artists who
needs crazy ass productions i need
[ __ ] fireworks and i'm not that guy
you know what i'm saying i'm trying to
make money right you know what i'm
saying so i'm actually like in those
meetings when they're sitting down and
they're going over how much this [ __ ]
cost and how much you know how much the
production of the show will be yeah how
long it's gonna take to get there uh you
know what venues we're gonna be able to
set all of this [ __ ] up at and some
venues if you're gonna have to have half
of the production a lot of people don't
take that [ __ ] into consideration when
they're like planning their events
they're just like
i wanna [ __ ] pop out of hell you know
what i mean and like as an artist like
that sounds cool but you gotta like
be realistic i just saw
i just saw mgk and he had a [ __ ]
helicopter well i don't blame him over
the [ __ ] arena it looked crazy i
don't blame him it was dope it was when
you get to that point where you want to
make those decisions
it's a helicopter or it's
bringing money home i'd rather bring the
money home not to say nothing bad about
anybody's business for sure but you know
i love art but i love my business like
i'm a businessman i got into this [ __ ]
to do business dog like you feel me so i
can get my point across with screens and
lights and my badge your energy cryo and
my energy and i got a couple other
little tricks so you got some hit
records
yeah you know what i'm saying and like
i'm really one of those people where
even if you don't know the words i'm
still gonna entertain you and bring you
in like uh
i'm that's my duty and job as a
performer you know what i'm saying so
it's been like that since day one and
it's gonna be like that with me being a
multi-platinum selling i'm still going
to invite you in to the record so
you know shout out to all of the crazy
ass production but i know how much that
[ __ ] cost and i don't want it uh you're
the first guy who i ever heard uzi with
yep also 21 savage oh cool that's crazy
yeah but like i remember you were like
practicing for one of your dj sets
playing like
some 21 savage [ __ ] it was the first
time i heard slaughter but i feel like
you have a crazy ear and you've always
had an ear in terms of like tapping in
my artist early outside of the guys
you're managing or who's on taylor gang
who are you a fan of right now that's of
the younger you know wave i haven't been
able to listen to nobody like not that i
don't enjoy it or just been in the
studio so much you've been
working yeah and like if i listen to
that [ __ ] i'm definitely gonna make a
song that sounds like it like because i
like that crowd i like the energy i like
entertaining i like talking [ __ ] so like
when i hear that [ __ ] i'm like oh yeah i
just heard this song you almost like
subconsciously influenced together i
mean it's like it's like a groove like
oh i heard this jam today i gotta have
something that hits like this like it's
not gonna be exactly like it but it's
gonna remind you of it it's gonna remind
me of it because i'm inspired so i
haven't really had a chance to like dive
in and like
build a list of songs where it's like if
i walk in the club i need to hear this
or if i get in a car if i'm if i'm about
to go to whatever
right i haven't even built that yet you
know you're not really like you're not
doing as many dj gigs because i mean i
just been in the studio i've been trying
to like you know what i mean like really
get this sound together and like who's
your dj named dj daddy daddy cat yeah
yeah
but if you give me some time you already
know my [ __ ] gonna be crazy i'm gonna
play some [ __ ] you never heard before
you but i had a [ __ ] wiz find another
song i never heard another artist
another blah blah blah that's what i do
you're pretty uh heavily involved in the
gaming thing uh you're part owner of a
gaming team yeah the pittsburgh knights
and i actually played uh
oculus with you for the first time i
ever played it yep and uh god damn i
almost that was some real cardio uh
which which game did you play we were
playing that shooting game remember you
fell and you hit your head on the coffee
table yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
just serious that [ __ ] got real yeah i
really thought somebody was shooting at
me dawg no it's like you gotta bend down
you gotta duck behind and then like a
bullet like cut like paws is flying at
your face
yeah yep you don't wanna yeah it got
real um how like do you like obviously i
know you do gaming events and you're on
twitch and stuff but are you like gaming
at the crib pretty often no i'm not
really like a big gamer uh i know my
place
and a lot of kids are really good at
that [ __ ] so they just want to just whip
my ass for like a game or two and then
get on with a day like i'm not there to
be good at anything
i'm just there to like support
make somebody's day you know what i mean
i don't i don't plan on getting too many
uh wins at anything did you see t
grizzly uh recently said he's making 200
grand a month off of twitch
i believe it because he's got he's got
like the gta server going and yeah yeah
[ __ ] is crazy yeah i believe it we were
just talking about that the other day it
was like
fool's making more off of that so like
why would they go do shows or you know
what i mean leave the crib like
but that's where the world is going and
it's going in that direction t-pain's
another one who's like killing it yeah
it's kid like it's going in that
direction there's more people
investing
in on their life online than they are
you know i'm saying in real life they're
buying more clothes online they're
buying cars online like fake clothes
yeah it's crazy it's for their avatar
you know
would you suggest people cause obviously
there's people who've been eating [ __ ]
on crypto recently and nfts and [ __ ]
like you're very smart with your money
like how involved did you get with the
crypto space not very smart
i had a lot of advice and you know i
feel like we took the right ones but i
did do a some you know to some degree
yeah yeah you dabbled yeah yeah it's not
you know me
turning a lot of money into
non-money yeah a lot of uh
well you know you saw like a lot of
people are like naughty probably not
even to their own knowledge like we're
like a part of ponzi schemes like
artists and like even the dude from the
sacramento kings
uh what scheme like like some of these
nft they call them like rug pools okay
so they they are like uh what's uh
darren fox who signed a 185 million
dollar contract for the kings
launched his own nft with a company
[Music]
and then i guess they sold like when
everyone bought in and then dipped so
they're like there's like that's like
that's yeah that's they're like it's a
lot looking great yeah you know what i'm
saying so that dude's in panama
somewhere chilling well also like you
signed a 185 million dollar contract
with the kings bro like yeah yeah no you
can't do that [ __ ] i believe it though
because it's like that's
all that they were going after is like
high quick money and it's also the quick
it's like that quick nutshell that's the
only way to get value that quick is to
go after somebody who's like high value
i mean you know what i mean so it's like
if you have a lighter and it's like it's
not really a lighter until [ __ ] like
libertarian
on the logo lebron touched it then it's
like oh yeah now we got these i got
lebron's lighter yeah it's like it's
cooler now you know what i'm saying so
they were doing that with like nfts and
all of those companies they were just
using artists to like promote them and
bring value to themselves but that [ __ ]
wasn't about nothing um how are you
feeling about uh mason rudolph being
your starting quarterback i don't watch
sports bro you don't watch the steelers
i mean i love this only if they make it
to the super bowl i've been yeah i've
been in the studio man you're
disconnected me and fed have a uh uh
a thousand dollar bet that the steelers
will not make the playoffs
so you're a fan i gotta talk about that
no no no
i'm just i'm hoping
i feel i feel good about my chances i
feel good about my chances man what's uh
yo your son is getting older uh you know
he's i feel like it was so dope to see
you guys do that oreo commercial yeah
way bigger than that now
now that like he's older he's kind of
like a little dude now you know what i
mean um
how do you do the work-life balance
because i feel like you do it so well
uh-huh because for me it's more about uh
spending time with him and making sure
he's good so i get i'll get the work out
of the way but i just scheduled my life
to where if you know he's got a ton of
[ __ ] to do if i got stunning [ __ ] to do
around around him i just won't have a
lot of work stuff
like
when you
grind for
10 plus years and work every [ __ ] day
and like go to the studio every day or
go to every meeting or do every drop
at a certain point you get to not have
to do all of that [ __ ] like you get to
do it when you want to yeah you've
worked you've worked so hard up until
this point to where you can say yeah and
raps not my only
thing you know what i'm saying like i
got voiceovers i got a ton of other [ __ ]
that you know i'm making money off of or
my companies that make money that i
don't even have to physically show up
for so if i have companies that i don't
have to physically show up for that are
bringing me millions of dollars
i can spend a ton of time with my son
you know what i'm saying
for that yeah i
afforded myself that and i made sure
that you know i
made that comfortability for myself a
lot of people don't think about that
[ __ ] they just think money money money
show show show blah blah blah all right
well how much money you're gonna make if
you don't go you know what i'm saying
and if you
and if it's none
you're not really a boss or you're not
really as paid as you think you are like
you got to get up and you got to go i'm
in chill here with my son i think the
pandemic uh unfortunately a lot of
people realized i'm not as rich as i
thought i was because but that wasn't it
the li the live show [ __ ] people were
getting like [ __ ] fake money what do
you mean like no i mean in terms of
lambos like [ __ ] no no no
i mean i mean artists i mean artists oh
artists no artists know that they're
broke because they have people who tell
them they're broke they just keep
spitting money yeah yeah they just be
like no i got a show for 100k next week
so i'm good no brother you just spent
70k
right you're not good but they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] and they don't
they don't care about
balancing that out because it takes too
much time effort and energy did you have
you ever seen an artist [ __ ] off
their money that you were cool with like
a young guy and you pull them to the
side and be like every last one of them
and yes i talked to them i pulled them
to the side yeah yep and did they listen
no
[Laughter]
hell no yeah the pandemic was crazy
everyone i knew was like rich all of a
sudden yeah fake money i was like
everyone's got [ __ ] designer and yeah
fake ass money it's cr it's great and
now some of them are in prison
or or they're you know or pending see
you what up we got to interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our people at blue chew don't forget to
go to bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg right now and
get your first month free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars in shipping it's
the uh man fellas the game changer
that's all i'm gonna say
you pop the blue chew and your dick is
on a million
man i'm not saying it makes it bigger
but it feels bigger i'm just saying i'm
not saying but i'm saying
uh look same active ingredient as cialis
and viagra
minus the awkward visits to the doctor's
office all right it's all over the phone
it's so easy they ship it right to your
door in discrete packaging
i don't know if you're going through
erectile dysfunction because you're
stressed out at work
uh maybe uh you just need a little extra
hump with wifey whatever it is maybe you
just want to take a bluetooth and beat
your dick like it stole something just
to feel like
damn that shit's hard bruh you know what
i'm saying go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and you
will save
all money it's free yeah you'll you'll
get a whole month for free
bluechew.com promo code bootleg for a
whole month for free delivered to your
door discreetly no doctor's appointments
no awkward visits same viagra cialis
ingredients
man what are you waiting for go do that
how did you get involved with liquid
death
um this company was brought to me i
think it was during the pandemic or
maybe before it's great waters at every
[ __ ] 7-eleven they were just like you
know we want to do a deal with you there
was some people who were tied in with
some people
that i'm really close with and they were
like we would love to work with whiz and
blah blah blah and it was just kind of
like an organic thing they were getting
started and i like the direction of how
they were doing it they were like we're
really extreme we don't give a [ __ ]
about the rules like the way we promote
is like really oh it's crazy hardcore
you know what i mean and it's like we're
going after it and they had a whole game
plan and it was linkedin with live
nation as well so every live nation
concert
uh venue liquid death is sold in so
that's me all summer you know what i'm
saying or anybody who is uh you know
with the company you're going to see
this company there so that's like how
you see monster energy drinks all over
the place this is [ __ ] water bro
so to me i'm like that's that's a big
big deal right there right that's why
everybody needs water no matter what
that's what we're going for
sign me up talk about the mr cap
mushroom play that you just announced
obviously uh you know i feel like
psilocybin is the future yeah it's it's
definitely uh i i don't know how legal
it is in canada it might be all the way
legal but in terms of just like the
legality of psilocybin in the united
states i feel like it's coming even yeah
yeah it's like how we was there's like
lobbyists fighting for it and there's
places where it's legal and then there's
places where they're just like
like right now it's like colorado i
think portland portland yeah portland
portland as well but it's not legal
enough to [ __ ]
sell
uh psilocybin so
we're not doing that in in the us i'm
like you see a lot of shrooms you see a
lot of like bar
chocolates and pills and [ __ ] like that
like that shit's not technically you
know
it's not
you know
you know what i'm saying not legal or
not i didn't say it but it's definitely
not legal yeah uh but a lot of people
are you know they're
mixing it and they're they're figuring
out ways to do it without the psilocybin
so like there's mushrooms that are like
kind of herbal you can grow them now
like they're making your own at-home
grow kids so when it does you know what
i mean people are already going to be
and they're doing this overseas and
there's places that and that's why we're
getting tapped in with mr cash because
there's places that i'm gonna be able to
like go full on with it and then there's
gonna be places where it's like a little
bit what's the us version of mr caps
gonna be you'll see okay but that's what
i'm telling you there's gonna be a
difference to save my ass so if i go to
amsterdam i might get some [ __ ] there
you go yeah there you go now we talking
have you ever had a terrible trip
no i i've i i wouldn't say terrible but
it's been pretty intense like mushrooms
to me is like a roller coaster like you
go up you get like really [ __ ] scared
and then like you drop and then it's
like intense and then you cruise for a
little bit and then it gets [ __ ]
intense again like whatever it might be
a loop a turn or whatever it is that's
how i literally got through rolling loud
just by eating shrooms the whole time
yeah but how much did you eat though uh
probably let's see throughout the week
we went through like two or three
eighths no three three eighths that's a
lot yeah we ate a lot it was me and this
guy right in a week yeah
dude trust me everything was real
realistic the whole the whole
[ __ ]
miami trip was see
i don't need that much shrooms i was at
booby trap
truman
it's a good time man it was a good time
all right so multiverse comes out friday
um
obviously badass [ __ ] is going up
uh i love that right i love the ice yo
ice down necklace was one of those
records that you played when i was there
and and at the time it sounded like the
greatest song i ever heard
it was the shrooms it was fun i was like
this [ __ ] is crazy i love iced out next
shout out to sledger he produced that
one that was one of the records that
that kicked off the multiverse
that was the first one right yeah yeah
yeah i uh we
i wrote the video and like we just
kind of that was like just setting up
kind of getting the vision back ready
and i just feel like that one has so
much energy that's going to be a
timeless song
that people just get rowdy to forever
and never like it doesn't matter
what happens today and i know by next
year like people are going to be [ __ ]
going crazy to that [ __ ] yo i wanted to
ask you did you and gilly the kid ever
chop it up after he was you know uh you
guys got into your no we didn't you
never did no you're very adamant about
keeping positivity around you at all
times i feel like i've noticed that
about you like
like if somebody's on some weirdo like
i'm not saying he is shout out to gilly
i'm a fan of the podcast but i mean in
terms of like i've seen like you be on
shows with other artists um
and they're just like not allowed in the
dressing room because the energy they're
off yeah yeah you know what i mean
because i like to help people
you know i'm a very positive person
so if
if i can help you i will and uh
did you learn that from snoop you feel
like
yeah well snoop's the big homie you know
and there's a lot of there was a lot of
situations like back in the day
that didn't even get past certain things
because snoop a call and be like yo
that's my little homie like
chill you know what i'm saying like
don't do that
and that was always i appreciated that
because he just knows my heart he knows
the people who are around me too
he's like look
just chill just relax you uh i saw there
was this weed olympics thing that
everybody was talking about did that
ever happen today right we're still in
we're still in the group chat but
supposed to be you burner currency be
real everybody got busy i think it's a
method man or red man i think the show
the show season kicked in and
[ __ ] got busy planning tours and like
[ __ ] just got sidetracked um yeah yeah
who is who's the underrated smoker in
hip-hop that can hang with you that we
don't obviously all the names i just
mentioned we all know are big smokers
but
i think ty is a pretty big smoker like
somebody who smokes a lot who's like who
you think it like you know
well
rico nasty rico nasty she's a g shout
out to her yeah can hang i think about
that viral video of you and snoop on
stage where you guys are yeah are doing
that yeah yeah yeah now ricochet
um is there anybody else that i was like
surprised i was like
she smokes a lot of weed i mean i
already shouted out miley cyrus she
smokes a [ __ ] ton of weed miley's a big
one huh yeah yeah she smokes a lot of
pie that was that was an era right the
23 record yeah that was shout out to
mike will made it yeah yeah that record
i felt like she was like a sleeper as
far as the pot goes
yeah
i mean i don't know i'm not like really
who else could hang as far as weed in
the game
like i was like man it smells like it
like really loves weed
that's just always rolling up i feel
like when i see you got the jars ready
yeah
there's never well i mean wheezy i don't
know if people still give him his credit
but wayne he smoked a [ __ ] ton of weed
me and him we we smoked weed from like
12
midnight to at least like eight o'clock
in the morning just non-stop smoking
weed do you feel like your tolerance is
so crazy now that like is it even
possible for you to like
like do you do you think back to like
when you maybe first started smoking
weed and how high do you how high you
would get because i feel like once you
like get into a pattern of smoking so
much like it it's obviously your
tolerance is higher yeah no i still get
[ __ ] stoned right i'll smoke like
four joints and be baked that's pretty
much the goal though like i wouldn't
want to be at the point where i didn't
get like smack you know right you're not
eating edibles though i [ __ ] with some
edibles that's whatever edibles are
terrible
they make my stomach hurt just a little
bit but like i'd rather do mushrooms
yeah no i tell people because people
think like oh it's eating weed i'm like
eating weed if you eat too much it's
worse than mushrooms yeah i'd rather
just do some shrooms and and and smoke
some weed but i take edibles for like
plane rides like long plane rides i do
more like thc pills you know what i'm
saying so it's not like in food form
because i don't eat a lot of candy and
goldfish and chocolate chip cookies and
[ __ ] sour patch kids and all that
like you know what i mean i'd rather
just take like a 25 milligram
bow you know what i'm saying go straight
that's a serious yeah yeah like two or
three of those i'm i'm sleepy have you
ever hallucinated off of an edible i
thought i overdosed for sure i woke up
and i was like it's it's the end of the
world did you puke
i thought i was going to but i i woke my
game up i was i was straight you're not
even cause i was on a plane and i didn't
want to throw up and then like get upset
and then that happened to me like a lot
like i feel like the last time i had
edible going onto a plane i thought it
was a great idea i was going to paris
for my girl
and then in the middle of the flat i
woke up freaking the [ __ ] out yeah and i
was in the [ __ ] middle seat it was it
was gonna make you puke but it's like
being in that
that
suction like that pause like it's a
different vibe you know what i mean
so
yeah we were we were playing are you um
are you gonna dabble in any more acting
obviously you you know you and snoop got
a movie there was the movie that you and
amber did where you were a cowboy
that was me being a supportive husband
yes
and i'll do it again yeah uh
yeah i met with uh
the people at amazon they got some [ __ ]
that they are really interested um some
scripted some non-scripted [ __ ] that
i've been working on
some uh some shows that are just like in
a cut like i got some pilots that we
shop in
i got this animated series that is like
kind of a spin-off of one that i was
already doing but it's more like an
adult animated because that shit's hella
popular so yeah i got a lot of stuff on
the table i'm just balancing it all out
especially with the album coming out
that's really important getting the tour
and then just making sure everything has
its own time like i don't want to be on
the road and filming at the same time
you know what i mean so i just
i make sure that um like i said i take
my comfortable
uh you don't over feel the comfort my
comfort and my happiness very very
serious um
you uh can you give me
obviously amber dropped a record yeah
what do you think of it i love it
shout outs are hard yeah i'm just like
you give her pointers you know what i
mean like she don't take pointers she
don't take pointers especially for men
right
but no i'm always i've always been
supportive and like you know encouraging
but if it wasn't fair
i would be like
you know it's cool but i think it's heat
it's not bad um
give me your top three tips for people
to co-parent out there because i feel
like you guys do it flawlessly top three
tips to co-parent if you're a man get
over yourself
uh if you're a man
don't give a woman advice on what she
should do uh take take [ __ ] full
responsibility accountability for your
actions
and don't be childish you know grow up
yeah yeah grow the [ __ ] up man there it
is where's khalifa the album is
this is multiverse multiplayer july 29th
on friday friday it's out it's out baby
it's great but how many how many records
is it um i think 17. 17. that's a nice
nice-sized body of work yeah nah that's
a complete body of work man you're gonna
get some food some full jams on there
there's like some eight-minute songs
first solo album in a while right like
in terms of just yeah cause i've been
dropping a lot of
[ __ ] with juicy yeah and not to not
count those records because i'm like yo
i haven't drawn music in forever i did
one ricardo and sledren
um no you just dropped the uh got wings
i did that one before that the other one
with juice yeah yeah i did the one with
girl talk and you know and create and
spit
so that's literally like three projects
already this is what i'm saying i'm
saying like your official solo album
it's been yeah but that's what i'm
saying it's the difference between this
one and all of those like all of those
i'm kind of just like yeah bro do
whatever but this one i really how many
how many has it been three years
what's since you dropped an album
um i wouldn't even count uh the album
that i put out in in 2020 like the the
saga because i was kind of just putting
out songs to
see what i like what the temperature was
so i would say like rolling papers two
was the last one and yeah what year did
that come out i feel like that was like
2017 18. yeah that was the last one damn
yeah yeah would you do part three or is
it over yeah i'll do part three you do
part three oh what there it is yeah yeah
there it is man well listen where's
khalif appreciate you pulling out nah no
doubt man anytime every time go get the
album and go support uh all the uh
liquid death
uh mcqueen yep go watch pfl on espn
khalifa kush khalifa kush smoke that
[ __ ] get the album
july 19th we're missing it friday smoke
khalifa kush to the album oh you're
missing we're missing another business
i'm forgetting oh the tour you said pfva
tour pfl
so much oh the the video game [ __ ] the
uh the knights the pack knight balls you
could order that on on on ubereats
like that if you see packed bowls by wiz
khalifa did you curate the menu it's one
of my yeah i've tasted all of them paws
and the the fried peanut butter and
jelly is crazy fried peanut butter and
jelly [ __ ] do you order your own
ubereats
sure
that's a that's the right answer
there it is where's khalifa